my name is nuru
i'm
a syrian portuguese
i left syria when i was 19 running away
from a war and trying to find a peaceful
place to start my life again
being a refugee simply means you are a
survivor someone had to move to
somewhere where
he can live peacefully being a refugee
means
a lot of struggle and challenges to
prove her that you deserve this chance
to to live
and talking about this chance to to be
here maybe it sounds simple for others
but for me and for people like me it's
not like that because what is simple
here it became like a dream for millions
of people
i was just lucky to have that
opportunity to be here
but i know that thousands and thousands
of people died trying to find a peaceful
place
proving for myself that i am able to
start again from zero was
the biggest motivation for me to be able
to survive every single day in my new
home it was not easy to be in a place
where you don't speak the language you
don't know anyone i was literally alone
so you had to face all of that and as
well to complete your life
in some part integration was not easy
when we talk about racist people
people who judge you just because you
are from somewhere or you believe in
something i realized that people have
wrong information
about
what does it mean to be a refugee people
were mixing between being a refugee and
being a migrant especially when i see in
the newspapers commenting and saying
send them back home there is no home it
was destroyed he is not a migrant who is
coming to find a better life a refugee
is someone is searching for a life
so i had to struggle with the
with the asylum system in portugal which
means sometimes i will give an example
of
exchanging my driving license from the
syrian one to the portuguese one
they asked me first to translate it with
the syrian npc
and i'm a refugee first that i should
not contact the regime and second there
is no syrian npc in portugal
so they asked me that without knowing
these two important details and when i
told them i can't they told me okay you
can translate it somewhere else
it was clear since the beginning that
there's a good intention from the
government but it's sometimes it's not
only about the intention it's also about
the practical things so
there is a problem in the law sometimes
and there is also solutions
and i think we need to point and put
some light on this kind of laws that
should be changed
so facing that personally
[Music]
it was a big motivation for me that i
should do something
i realized that
without telling the government about
this these issues they will never know
that these
issues are exist
and
[Music]
the good thing that the government in
portugal was giving an ear and trying to
to listen and they they tried also to
change something they did well and i do
believe they can do more still
i think the thing i would like to add
and i believe it will change a lot in
the process of
integration and inclusion for refugees
and migrants in europe
is including them in your meetings and
discussions about them
this will help you a lot to understand
the full picture of the life of migrants
and refugees in europe without knowing
the details of their basic daily life
sometimes you may
create a problem instead of creating
solution
so i think involving them in your
discussions
and
give them a voice
it's very important because before when
i was complaining about something
there's always that people who will say
but who you are
you are not portuguese if you don't like
this country get out of here
as a syrian
i was meeting a lot of syrian armenians
in my country
and i know in the history that they ran
away from a war and they came as
refugees to syria and they became
syrians
i never felt that they should be
grateful because we receive them
i think this is very
very basic human rights for anyone on
earth to find a peaceful place and live
meet people from different culture
from different background and be able to
connect with them and to see that
differences as bridges not as a barriers
in a country like portugal they helped
me to integrate you know they tried to
show me that i'm part of them even i'm
syrian i'm a muslim even i am a
foreigner who just came to the country i
felt connected and related to this
country even before i get the
citizenship document i always felt i'm
portuguese i always felt i am one of
them i still remember that stadium thing
when i went to watch the match
and friend of mine
watched me there and he just came and he
put the scarf of the club
on my neck and he said you are
portuguese now and i was not portuguese
at that time you know maybe i was not
portuguese on the paper but for them i
was poor because i was one of them
[Music]